they had uh a lot of whiskey with Rogan
once I think I saw that yeah I think I
saw that with Whitney too he was in the
push-up concert contest with uh David
got is the only time I met David Goggins
in person one of the great
embarrassments of my life is uh trashed
out of my mind I'm trying to say how
much of a fan I am and I could tell by
the look in his eye that what is
actually coming out of my mouth is not
good
it's not good and his wife is
embarrassed standing right there also
just everybody's embarrassed for me man
I'm trying my best and then somehow I
find myself a minute later doing
push-ups with him as a challenge I
didn't it wasn't counting all I knew I'm
not stopping
and he was polite enough to stop I think
probably like 50 I don't know
there's a gift someone gives you when
they get drunk and they allow they get
drunk and they lower their guard and
they allow you to see them that way it's
a gift it's a real gift it's just as
cool as like pulling someone's side and
going yo I'm into anime like are you
cool with that and then they're going
yeah oh yeah can I show you some cool
anime and then you're like that's not my
thing but it's like a cool thing it's
like sharing cool music with someone or
like telling them something about your
childhood when you when you get drunk
like real drunk around someone
you're giving them a gift yeah and that
gift is I want you to see me for
everything I am yeah you're not going to
get any lies you're not going to get any
[__] this is me at my absolute worst
I have a rule I will never never get mad
at someone for getting too [__] up
because they're giving you a gift
they're saying like yo I did this on
accident but I trust you enough to let
you know that this is who I am and this
is what you're getting I love it I love
it especially when it comes to someone
you don't expect like you shut the [__]
up David gockins should have hugged you
and said thanks for showing me this yeah
I guess that really you're right I
haven't thought of it that way there's
an intimacy to that because that is a
gift of like fragility like this is me I
mean I'm I'm a very loving drunk but I'm
boy am I a dumb drunk
well dumb in terms of the eloquence of
the words that are coming out of my
mouth so like you're just not stitching
words together correctly to make
sentences no I turn into Hemingway Lost
in Translation like I'll start saying
random words but like translated to
Japanese and back to English it's not
making any sense but there's love like I
think what you feel is this kind of
desire to connect that I think I always
feel towards other people but when I'm
drunk I'm just say [__] it I don't need
to be polite I'll just be loving fully
yeah yeah it's uh
it's cool when people let you see that
in them because some people are really
like measured like not one drink and
then I'm done I don't want it no no no
no and you're like show me a little more
and then like it's cool and I never be
like and I love my favorite moments in
the next morning when they're like did I
make an ass out of myself and you get to
say not at all yeah not at all that's
the coolest thing because some people
bad people will leverage that over yeah
you can you can see it's a bully tactic
they'll leverage that the bad
interactions I've had with in this
business
that we were talking about earlier
they were people that that when you got
[__] up they used it against you yeah
they held it over your head and they
said listen man
I don't know what the [__] but if you
want and you're like hold on and then
and then they made you they Gaslight you
into thinking you're the only one that
was [__] up and you're like okay I
guess I know who you are now and I was
like didn't you get [__] up a little
bit too yeah like I know he smokes weed
and I thought we ate Xanax but like what
about the I know I had a couple beers
but like I wasn't that [__] up
well Whitney's really good at that
because she's the person I woke up next
morning and she just she said yeah
you're wonderful you are eloquent you
were great I I'm sure she was making
that up completely it was funny I got
blackout drunk at Whitney's roast of me
like black don't remember any of it and
don't remember any of it don't remember
speaking on the microphone I don't
remember talking in the microphone
and and I I did the set apparently yeah
and I said to Whitney like in a real
moment of vulnerability Whitney's like a
sister to me like a legit sister
my daughter's call her aunt Whitney
Leanne shook his sister Leanne if she
comes over to do a podcast with Neil
show up an hour early and sit with
Leanne out in Leon's rose garden and
just talk and Whitney I
I said the next day I called Whitney and
I was getting on a plane
and I was new I was hungover I said how
bad was I last night she goes you were
[__] fantastic and just didn't let me
sit with it and then I watched the video
and I was like oh I was [__] out of
control I was way out of control thank
you for lying to me yeah so while being
a wild out there comic she's also this
like caring and loving human being she's
so interesting she is she is the most
nurturing
Sensibility
she is you she sends my daughter's gifts
out of nowhere just out of nowhere to
send Georgia gifts up to college it's
just a gift box like she is just she
takes care of people that's her love
language and she's also the person that
taught me what what the hell love
language even means apparently there's a
book and there's like five of them oh
you and Whitney I would love to sit in
the [__] room and watch YouTube talk
yeah she has a robot yeah it looks like
her
and um
that's the future that robot I told her
she should have that robot do porn
unless someone [__] that robot and then
and she can she get deep faked the face
if she wants but I go
promote it promote a special that way
like a full-on not like Showtime
softcore porn like full-on foreign
full-on like the dude like it's like hi
welcome inside you looked tired do you
need a drink yeah oops I'm stuck in the
dryer